hey guys I'm Lucy and welcome once again
to in two minutes it's a little early
this year but we've got another
Assassin's Creed game out this week now
I actually quite like Assassin's Creed
granted it's a series not really known
for its innovation but the gradual
iteration year-on-year makes it quite a
comfortable game it's familiar like an
old jumper that fits you just write that
you only wear when you're home alone
because you're actually a little ashamed
of liking it so much I guess what I'm
saying is you know what you're getting
with this a sins creed but of course to
keep people interested you got to treat
the form you're a little bit so here's
five tweaks to look out for in
Assassin's Creed syndicate it's all
London baby here we go we've got a new
city to explore under new ruckus to get
involved in the industrial revolution in
19th century London the rift between the
poor working class and the rich elite is
growing ever larger and the Templar
order ruled the city seven unique
boroughs London is thirty percent larger
than lunacies Paris and is full of death
traps hanging crates exploding barrels
and the murky Thames all in all making
the big smoker rather dangerous place to
frequent and speaking of burrows while
yes famous districts like Westminster
and Southwark will get a look in the
river thames is going to be its own
Beast sorry borough if you think about
it the Thames was and indeed is crucial
to London's financial success and while
there will be any proper naval combat if
you're a fan of Black Flag swashbuckling
ways there are still elements of piracy
in syndicate you can Nick people's cargo
new time period equals a new arsenal the
rise of high society meant that it just
wasn't proper to openly carry weapons
around with you so the frightens have to
make do with knocking the stuffing out
of nerdy wells with brass knuckles
poison gas a sword disguised as a cane
guns and of course and Nepalese machete
of course there's your standard-issue
hidden blade but overall syndicate is
more about the fisticuffs and the
fencing either in underground fight
clubs or when booting Templars out of
london's boroughs there's a lot of
brawling to be getting on with to make
combat more interesting new be soft are
bringing back the multi kill from
Assassin's Creed 3 soften up two or more
enemies with a bit of pummeling and then
all out in one fell swoop certainly more
satisfying than taking everyone out one
by one as per usual London's a bit of a
pain to get around I should know I have
to get the tube every day so syndicate
gives players a few new options to get
from A to B you can hop on the back of a
steam engine which also doubles as a
mobile secret base of assassin
operations or you can hail / steal a
horse drawn carriage and run over a
couple of Templars with it there's
steamboats to avoid getting your
assassin boots damp and the new Arkham
escrow clauncher to zip across the sky
on with although if it were like the
real London I bet a ticket for the above
would be super expensive so has the ship
sailed for a seventh grade or are you
gonna dawn that comfy jumper just one
more time let me know in the comments
section below I'll come find me on
Twitter I'm Melissa James games and I'll
see you next time
you